Gott ist mein Hirte religiöser Content
auf Social Media
[Musik]
aber in der Schweiz kommt es immer mehr
reicht es aus ein guter Mensch zu sein
um in den Himmel zu kommen die Bibel die
ist Gott wirklich Fleisch wurde
konvertiert zum Islam natürlich als
reiner
[Musik]
überzeugungordnung Kommunikation
zwei Frauen wo Social Media als große
Chance gesehen für ihre glauben
[Musik]
eine vor deine Frau mein Bruder sich auf
Social Media jetzt Sprachrohr vom
islamische Zentralrat Verein für dir
Musliminnen und Muslime wo strickt noch
im Koran Leben
finster hätte der etc über 10.000
Follower sie ist aber ganz analog auf
der Straße unterwegs
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nur mit einer Person
noch immer hinter der strenger Ideologie
vor dem Verein
also für mich
und
klar es hat immer irgendwelche
Nachteile
der Generalverdacht und nicht von
ungefähr der Verein repräsentiert
zanunkeln
der Schweiz aber er sagt immer wieder
für medialer Wirbel das letzte
sind schon verurteilt worden vom
Bundesgericht der Extremismus wo man ist
immer wieder zuschreibt da ist nicht
vorhanden
Verurteilung
wie gesagt
ja das ist
einfach
okay genau
und Produktionsstudio vom Verein wurde
Content für Youtube produziert wird
da steckt richtig Geld drinnen und der
Wille zum Promo machen für ihre idealen
Lebensvorstellung man muss sich
Equipment aber vor allem auch Ideen und
Sachen Technik
[Musik]
geschnitten
ich finde das
Video für YouTube wo sie fast 20.000
[Musik]
1 2 und
Aktion es ist nicht nur so dass die
mütterer
aber nicht jedes Wochenende
das Video sollten später auf Youtube
landen
[Musik]
wie andere Videos in der Vergangenheit
aber Provokation ist natürlich aus
Mittel zum Zweck über genau das möchte
mit der Silvia Martens vom Zentrum für
Religionsforschung an der Uni Luzern
reden
umstritten sind sie weil sie sehr gern
und sehr bewusst provozieren
auch
über Grenzen gehen oder an die Grenzen
gehen auch an
Aufmerksamkeit so generieren wollen und
das war bisher stark so auf der bezogen
auf politische aktivistische Bereiche
und fahren in der wie sie in der
Öffentlichkeit auftreten und sie sind
radikal im Sinne von sie vertreten
Ansichten die sozusagen
über das hinausgehen was der muslimische
Mainstream vertreten würde sie sind auch
nicht sie schauen sich nicht davor die
auch explizit zum Teil auszudrücken und
damit auch zu provozieren die
terror-propaganda Geschichte sind
verurteilt oder zwei von ihnen in einer
schönen ohne
nein das ist nicht ohne und vielleicht
haben Sie auch dort Grenzen
überschritten oder austesten wollen die
wo sie nicht genau wussten wurde wozu
das führt ich habe das Gefühl nach
dieser Erfahrung ist man viel ruhiger
geworden in diesem allgemeinen
politischen Bereich ich denke sie haben
gemerkt dass es vielleicht zu viel war
das ist nicht ähm eben welche
Konsequenzen das hat auch juristische
Konsequenzen und sind dann sanfter
geworden das ist irgendwie jedenfalls so
beobachten über die Zeit laut
Landeskirche höchstens doof langsam
geht's Podcasts und youtube Channels und
Co und Sido macht auf eigene Fust
Content für die reformierte Kirche auf
Social Media
ja und deshalb sind wir jetzt da in
Sumiswald im Emmental es ist morgen früh
am suntig bald gibt es da der
Gottesdienst und Pfarrerin von dort mir
hier Zimmermann dir redet eben nicht nur
in der Kirche über Gott sondern auch auf
Social Media
Gottesdienst vorbereitet hat und mit dem
Sundern wieso sind das macht und wie sie
das macht
10 Jahre Fahrerin da und dort wird
Institution Kirche wo viele gar nicht
sieht gemäß empfinden finden
[Musik]
also ich danke zum Glauben in erster
Linie ist persönliches Erlaubnis mit
Gott
vor
das Haar Überzüge aber vielleicht tut es
auf Gott aufmerksam machen und genau das
macht Miriam es Gabi
schwieriger
ist der unterschiedlich ich glaube es
ist schwer es ist für sie glaube relativ
natürlich
dass sie mit mir so kommunizieren also
dass sie mir morgen ist WhatsApp
geschrieben oder irgendwie auf insta
oder so
wirklich
[Musik]
was die ganze Arbeit eines Tages bringt
das ganze jetzt Kirchenaustritt
verhindert oder generiert ist umstritten
auf Instagram aktiv
[Musik]
sind im 21 aus der evangelische und
katholische Kirche
[Musik]
verhindern mit ihren knapp Überdosis
hätte ihre Strahlkraft aber nur
Potenzial
mit vier von Bürgern aber Jesus
aldenwärme wenn es mal napolig ich finde
eigentlich unglaublich gut auf Instagram
würde ich gerne hätte ich lieber so wie
du bist
aber ich glaube das ist einfach immer
wenn du im Messen
immer religiöse Bereich ist oder suchst
Social Media
abholen
aber
kirchlichen Kontext hätten hätten
spezifische Begriff dafür nämlich
passioniere
schatz
du bist genau okay so wie Du willst du
bist und ähm
dem Glauben und an der Freude oder eine
gute Nachricht und ich finde halt als
Kind
möchte das Social Media eines Tages zu
ihren offizielle Aufgabe gehört und
entlöhnt wird in Deutschland ist es
schon Realität ich bin evangelische
Pfarrerin in Berlin und jetzt ganz
[Musik]
Fahrräder und fahre schaffen die
professioneller mit Social Media das
merkt man auch oder Followerzahlen
während Landeskirche in der Schweiz oder
Kinderschuh steckend sind Vertreter vor
Freikirche sogenannte
christ-300
er Sabrina Müller beobachtet religiöse
influencer auf Instagram schon seit
mehrere naja
das Spiel ganz fest Organisation
ich werde jetzt aktiv
im Hintergrund
die aktuellen Zahlen immer aber ich
glaube mehr oder vielleicht kann dir
über Europa
mit dem Zentralrat der Organisation im
Rückgang für die Accounts erstellt sie
mit ihrem Team Content für Youtube insta
und Co
so hässlich hier
so erzählen
okay
wir Facebook einen Event vom islamische
zentralratal know und ich als Host
entdeckt wurde weißt du bist
und sich engagiert hätte Gefühl dass ihr
so auch kein grüner wohnen können was
noch kommen
dass ich definitiv ortsziel also aber
das ist jetzt nicht so dass man
irgendwie rekrutiere und so und aus der
spezifisch
ihre Inhalt richten sich an Musliminnen
und Muslime vor allem dir wenn sie für
ihre radikale Ideologie Gründer zwei
Monaten
[Musik]
und das ist halt immer islamischer
mir zurückgenommen
ihre Moschee ich habe jetzt Internet für
Klicks generieren
Marketingprofis in eigener Sache ganz
genau
[Musik]
so was eine klären ich bin eine zwei
Frauen ich denke Dir wo schon glaubend
ihr könnt mit dem Content auf Social
Media tatsächlich
interessant für mich z.B also mir holt
jetzt überhaupt nicht ab und er hat
irgendwie mit Zweifel dass das dreckig
ist für Glaubenskrise in der Schweiz
aber wer weiß was glaubst Du Religion
braucht genauso Leute auf Social Media
für Gott ist statt oder findest du hätte
religion und Glaube gar nichts zu suchen
diskutieren darüber in die Kommentar ich
freue mich schon von dir zu und wenn du
schon da bist abonniere doch neue Kanal
und locken das
verlinkt hat dass ich sie bis zum
nächsten Mal